jusqu'à présent toute personne
conduisant sous stupéfiant ou alcool
était sanctionné d'un retrait de six
points Gérald Darmanin veut désormais
retirer la totalité on arrête les
retraites point pour les petits excès de
vitesse moins de 5 km/h en revanche on
prive de permis de conduire ce qui
conduit ce stupéfiant et sous alcool
renforcer les sanctions au-dessus de 0,8
g par litre de sang mais aussi renommée
en homicide routier les accidents
mortels dû à la drogue et à l'alcool
c'est-à-dire deux ricards
je donne pas mon avis mais vous le
connaissez Gilles Verdez qui dit non
mais voilà vache c'est insupportable
en fait
excusez-moi il y a oui ou non j'ai le
droit de dire non quoi alors est-ce
qu'on est-ce qu'on le laisse démarrer
ouais allez vas-y Gilles personne
d'autre me dit non non il y a plusieurs
choses d'abord on réagit pas quand on
est ministre sous l'émotion d'un fait
diversification
heureusement qu'il est là pour réagir
avec
de réagir direct et de réagir à chaud on
en a marre des gens qui disent on attend
on verra c'est exactement ce que veulent
les Français tu veux que je te dise il a
réagi comme bol les Français ils n'ont
pas comme comme tu veux toi et tu veux
te dire comme je te dis à chaque fois
que je t'aime beaucoup tu es vraiment la
France du passé merci mon Gilles je vais
peut-être dire oui finalement
deuxièmement je trouve ça hyper
démagogique pourquoi parce que c'est
inapplicable c'est-à-dire que il n'y a
pas mais il n'y a pas assez de test il
dit j'en veux un million il y en a pas
et ce qu'il y a des gendarmes ou des
policiers pour faire les tests sur les
routes non donc il y a des gens qui vont
continuer de conduire comme ça donc il
faut agir avant la répression ne sert à
rien c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas
applicable troisième point les drogues
de synthèse dont on parle dans l'affaire
Palmade les drogues de synthèse ne sont
pas détectables dans ces tests
tu vas détecter le truc
insupportable mais toi si on t'écoute on
fait rien avec un peu mais on sait rien
mais on fait le truc c'est que tu vas
dans tous les pays où c'est où la
répression à ce niveau-là et bah
bizarrement il y a pas de problème donc
à un moment donné ou peut-être qu'il
faut séduire tu trouves pas mais non
mais c'est pas applicable ma chérie
arrête avec lui arrête avec lui tu vois
bien qu'il veut et lui il veut rien
faire lui il voit un mec rentrer chez
lui sur son tapis et lui dire ce que je
vous sers un verre non non mais je te
jure non mais arrêtez les mecs il y a un
argument qui irait dans le sens
qu'il n'a pas énoncé c'est celui de des
gens qui vont du coup rouler sans permis
c'est c'est l'argument que déjà on est
le pays d'Europe où on a le plus de gens
qui roulent sans permis pourquoi parce
que c'est juste une amende parce qu'on a
le permis à point voilà cette décision
là du coup les gens vont rouler sans
permis parce que et ben ils n'auront
plus accès à leur travail et donc ils
seront bien obligés d'y aller quand même
et que ça risque d'avoir de faire
exploser le nombre de gens qui
rouleraient sans permis
j'ai rien compris à son dernier SMS
16% des contrôles de drogue sont
positifs donc ça montre bien que les
gens qui en prennent n'ont pas
conscience du danger ils sont des
dangers
quand on se drogue aussi et en plus
quand on a l'irresponsabilité de
conduire un faux retirer le permis c'est
c'est quoi tu répondes à Gilles non mais
déjà non il y a déjà il faudrait
supprimer le permis à point ça c'est un
fait effectivement
après oui évidemment qu'il faut il faut
il faut qu'il le fasse le problème et ça
c'est vrai pourquoi pourquoi il s'est
pas fait pour le moment c'est que ça
coûte très cher et ça on le dit pas les
tests anti-drogue et tout ça ça coûte
très cher je crois qu'on est à 1 ou 2 €
le test et c'est pour ça que pour
l'instant ils peuvent pas le faire ils
n'ont pas l'argent pour le faire
maintenant effectivement quand je vois
que moi il y a pas longtemps j'étais
vitesse retenue 56 dans Paris et qui
vous emmerde pour des trucs pareils
alors que les gens qui connaissent
drogués et bourré oui il faut mettre
l'argent ailleurs mais les tests coûtent
très cher et là où je rejoins en
revanche il c'est que si on débloque pas
d'argent pour la police bien sûr c'est
un peu pieux oui Raymond tu auras tout
ça tu les auras les moyens aujourd'hui
il y a les moyens d'arrêter des gens sur
la route il les arrête donc sauf que
c'est les mesures qui changent les
moyens tu les auras quand même bonne
résolution pour les 5 km/h de pas
enlever de points pour 5 km voilà bougie
il a vu des gens il y a des gens qui
roulent à 52 au lieu de 50 tu en fais
des chômeurs en puissance parce qu'après
ils faire de leur taf c'est surtout tu
en fais des mecs qui roulent sans permis
et quand il te tape toi ta voiture sans
permis il y a pas d'assurance
c'est-à-dire quand il y a pas de permis
il y a pas d'assurance ça c'est une
bonne mesure et l'autre bonne mesure moi
je suis pour c'est 08 ça veut dire trois
verres ça veut dire que tu as pris la
route à partir du 4e 5e 6e vers les
époques elles changent comme vous avez
dit tout à l'heure on est en 2023 on
peut plus permettre en 2023 de rouler
nous normalement sans avoir rien fait se
faire taper par un mec qui est
complètement sous calme sous sushi ou
sous-alcool et toi tu finis dans un
fauteuil roulant et lui il a rien et toi
tu fais tes jours à regarder par la
fenêtre donc lui continue à faire ses
conneries c'est pas possible
je regarde tout le monde c'est pas
possible d'entendre comme les histoires
qu'on a eu de faits divers ces derniers
temps des gens qui n'ont rien fait qui
circulent normalement et dire aux gens
aussi que le cannabis et là tout ce qui
est tout ce qui est drogue c'est 15
jours c'est 10 jours 15 jours dans dans
le sang ça veut dire que tu peux te
droguer ou faire du shit pendant deux
trois jours et pas et pas conduire au
bout du 5e 6e jour 10e jour tu te fais
contrôler tu seras positif donc
maintenant on arrête les conneries et on
se met à la place de quelqu'un qui s'est
fait cartonner avec l'alcool au volant
et si tu perds ton enfant parce que le
mec il
ce qu'il avait percuté un groupe de 8
cyclistes il en a grillé grièvement
blessé trois il était récidiviste
c'était la quatrième fois qu'il était
pris en état d'ivresse au volant à 31
ans et il était encore sur la route et
là il a fait un grave accident ça il ne
faut plus que ça se reproduise 4 fois
c'est impensable donc voilà il y a un
vrai problème il faut au moins prendre
déjà cette mesure qui n'est pas le
camion
je vais vous raconter un truc que je
faisais dans les années 80 personnes 30
secondes pour pour voir comment les
mentalités elles changent et pour voir
comment moi aussi à l'instar de billard
j'ai aussi changé on commençait le matin
à 5h30 avec du café calva café calva on
conduisait des camions ensuite on
partait tous en livraison et on
commençait chez les clients à 8h du
matin un tir 9h un tiers 10 heures apéro
parce que avant c'était pas l'apéro
avant c'était rien et on commençait les
entrecôtes un demi une bière après on va
faut passer à table il est midi du vin
et on faisait comme ça et on rentrait à
15-16 heures les camions complètement
bourrés on rentrait tous complètement
bourré dans les années 95 95 97 les
années 200 il y a plein de chauffeurs
plein de chauffeurs routiers encore
aujourd'hui qui roule bourré faut
prendre conscience qu'on peut plus
maintenant moi je le fais plus
maintenant c'est terminé tu me connais
tu vois bien que je fais plus ça je
prends plus là la voiture si je suis
complètement éclaté encore éclater non
mais voilà parce que tu accompagnent
vraiment changer les comportements ça y
est on est en 2023 tu peux plus entendre
en 2023 j'ai bu 5 verres ça c'est non
c'est pas possible on prend pas ta
voiture maintenant il y a les moyens il
y a Hubert il y a les taxis tu laisses
ta voiture tu reviens le lendemain tu
peux pas aller tuer une gamine ou un mec
t'a rien fait juste parce que toi tu as
voulu boire 5 verres de vin c'est fini
ça c'est un assassin par exemple qui
sont des mots qui sont en boîte de nuit
qui sont à 20 à bord de chez eux en plus
au bout de trois verres au bout de
quatre verres aujourd'hui avec les
moyens d'aujourd'hui il faut changer les
mentalités pas les gens ils le font les
fois c'est les anciens comme nous qui
font pas ça allez